twitter's new earnings report is out and
uh i gotta say i called it their
earnings were down it was obvious but in
this revelation in this document we
learned something else
and people are already claiming fraud
twice
twitter accidentally so they say
inflated their user numbers
that means
that when they sold advertisements it
was against false numbers that means
when elon musk agreed to buy the company
it was based on false numbers and even
the left-wing verge the verge.com says
how did this happen twice
now
many of us are speculating on the weird
shift in user growth
right leaning channels or right
sphere of influence associated channels
are seeing major gains left sphere of
influence are seeing major decline
i think they were running fake accounts
i think they were banning people on the
right and creating fake accounts for
people on the left
since tuesday i have gained 100 000
followers which is around 10 percent of
my follower count 10 strange because i
noticed a lot of other people have a
similar number of around eight to ten
percent
the weird thing is that it starts on
tuesday on monday when the news broke
nothing so we're gonna get into all of
that and boy is this story getting crazy
then we also have elon musk tweeting a
meme showing the left going super far
left leaving moderates on the right now
and we're gonna talk about that because
even barack obama is now a conservative
according to cnn and the washington post
cnn plus
shut down two days early they couldn't
even fail
by their fail date they had to actually
fail earlier than normal because it
failed so bad
we had some stories out of kenosha joy
reid is getting canceled james corden is
quitting
yo what's going on it's all like all of
a sudden the damn broke and now we're
all charging the hill to take the high
ground sounds good let's talk about it
joining us to talk about all of this is
pronounce your i'm going to pronounce
your next name along negrosia nicosia
all right well john introduce yourself
i'm john nicosia there you go there you
go president newscycle media
well so what's your what's your
background what do you do
um
so i'm in the media i was at mediatek
for eight years uh then ijr and then to
the washington examiners the breaking
news editor i want a down thing and now
just uh consulting
right on and breaking news
you've got some stories from the inner
workings of you know the rise in digital
media and all that stuff so i think
that'll be particularly interesting
considering all the context we've got
yeah there's a lot going on and i think
there's a reset about to happen
certainly at cnn um and i think that'll
i think a site that big is gonna
create a wave along with you know this
happening with twitter i think there's a
lot of opportunities for sites to
reinvent themselves because right now
the
the amount of people who hate media
outnumbers the people actually watching
media
and i think you're going to start to see
people like reed and other people who
have no audiences that are just kind of
there
uh brian stelter and other people who
just exist to um set narratives are
going to find that they don't have a job
anymore i don't think brian stelter has
an audience no i i genuinely mean that
yeah i mean it's baffling i mean there's
a
there's a
there's a school of thought that he um
was there as
zucker's henchman which you know i
happen to be there in january of 2017
when uh trump called uh um
what's his name fake news pointed down
jim acosta yeah jim acosta and i was
sitting in the head of pr's office which
is across from zuckers and selter had
just come off the air and when he did it
they basically said well looks like
we're going to war for four years wow
and they did i mean i thought it was a
joke at the time so i think brian served
a purpose for i mean you know john ryan
was part of a a website called tv newser
back in the day that covered
the media you know and he has some chops
on that and then you know everyone just
fell apart during trump trump broke him
we'll we'll talk about that there's a
lot of interesting stuff going on we
talked a bit about with with these
personalities quitting and imploding but
uh we'll get to all that so thanks for
hanging out john and we've got the
sheamus sheamus i run a youtube channel
called freedom tunes we upload once a
week with the exception of this week
we're actually going to be uploading
extra content next week so go over there
subscribe hit the notification bell i
love you all it's exciting for the show
it's interesting you said that zucker
said a four-year war it was about to
commence in 2017 because it does feel
like they lost last year yeah cnn
my numbers also are up two thousand
percent on twitter i got fifty followers
one thousand percent and then i got
fifty on monday and then uh one thousand
one hundred and fifteen on tuesday from
fifty to one thousand um
it feels like in the culture war that we
won a big battle a big battle was one
when elon put forth this buy deal and
now the enemy's in a route it's as if
we're taking multiple hill after hill
repositioning our strategic offense it's
true it's like as soon as elon it's like
you know uh like gandalf in uh battle
for helms deep
we we go for one last ride storming
through the orcs and then we see up on
the hill and the sunlight comes in and
then all of a sudden the herons are
charging down but uh it's not just as
soon as that happened it's like all of a
sudden every front like you were saying
in just different fields started getting
taken
wow we'll talk about it yeah this is why
they have a ministry of truth now that
they've announced right yeah we're
winning they're starting to win i think
you're right i think they're starting to
notice the mainstream media is falling
and that has been the pr wing of the
democratic party so i think that's why
and i think people had a lot to say um
and now they're not as afraid with elon
out there i think they see somebody
putting money up to yeah you know bring
back some level of balance well isn't it
incredible how as soon as elon musk said
he wanted to have more fair and
equitable rules on the website that
would allow people from both sides of
the political aisle to voice their
opinions people on the left freaked out
and then people on the right just
started posting like crazy well we'll
see we'll see a lot to say about this so
uh of course lydia is pressing the
button yeah i am that's what i'm doing
in the corner
jumping in yeah pushing buttons over
here all right but we'll talk about that
first big story where it looks like
twitter uh twitter lied or or was
actually wrong before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
to help support our work as a member
you'll get access to exclusive segments
of this show monday through thursday at
8 00 pm i'm sorry at 11 pm i always do
that 11 pm these are the uncensored not
family-friendly versions of the show
where we all swear quite a bit and get
angry about stuff and that's at
timcast.com but as a member you are
supporting our journalists we're going
to be hiring more we're going to be
doing more shows we are about to do some
big marketing moves we've been marketing
chicken city which has been very very
successful but that's more of like a a
hokey kind of family thing we really are
going to start doing a big push for our
tales from the inverted world we're
going to be hiring more journalists
because we want to engage with culture
create culture and challenge the
cultural establishment with your support
as members at timcast.com we will do it
so don't forget to also smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends take that url
right now post it everywhere that's the
most powerful thing you can do we have
done no marketing ever for this show and
it's about to change
but uh the grassroots marketing really
has made all this possible so thank you
guys so much let's check out this first
story from the verge
twitter miscounted its daily users for
three years straight how did this happen
twice yo the verge is a progressive
website when they point out you're doing
something wrong something must be really
wrong they report twitter overstated the
number of daily users on its service for
three years straight over counting by up
to 1.9 million users each quarter the
error was due to twitter inadvertently
counting multiple accounts as active
when they were all tied to a single user
even if they weren't in use these
incorrect usage numbers were given for
q1 2019 through q4 2021
this somehow this is somehow not the
first time twitter has done this in 2017
twitter also realized it had been
overstating its user figures by one to
two million for three years the repeat
mistake was revealed today in twitter's
earnings release for the first quarter
of 2022. here's the amazing thing the
earnings report was bad
they were they were down a bit i think
was it like 30 million less they uh it
was let me just pull the timcast.com
article twitter's earnings report shows
missed revenue projections
they were they were uh projecting 1.23
billion making only 1.2 billion now
that's not that bad but their money is
going down and i predicted this this
likely in my opinion would have resulted
in a stock drop off but because elon has
already agreed to buy it stock is likely
going up or staying the same in fact the
fact the stock isn't currently sitting
at 54.20 says to me there are some
people who think the deal won't go
through and it's possible but this is
big and it could be a reason
many people on twitter are now saying
this sounds like fraud yo like twitter
was lying they were lying to their
advertisers they lied to elon musk i
don't think elon musk would decide not
to buy the platform now but i wonder
what this means for the deal and i
wonder what it means for twitter's
executives if is anybody going to get in
trouble yeah i mean elon's ability to
negotiate downwards um also of course
let's point out the fact that twitter
which has decided that they would take
it upon themselves to determine what was
or was not misinformation in the outside
world would not even deliver accurate
figures on how their website was doing
i'll tell you man i work behind the
scenes at mines developing that company
for a decade and there is no way that
they did not know that one person with
five accounts is not one person they
they're intentionally allowing that to
play for for to overvalue the company
this is insidious let's let's let's
drive i don't know that for sure of
course i can't i can't prove that let's
drive this point home ian you were a
co-founder at minds.com yeah a social
media platform with millions of users
yeah you watched you've seen internals
you actually moderated the platform yeah
in your expert opinion having run social
media infrastructure twitter knew that
that was wrong i bet so there are 7 500
yes yes they there are so many employees
of that company 7 500 plus employees i
would imagine 30 percent probably 10 of
them knew that's a good point too
not a single person said hey wait a
minute guys i think if you've got a
company that knows if somebody
misgendered somebody uh
you know if somebody and that can shut
them down and are that deep into
the daily workings of their site that
they didn't somehow know how many people
were using it is kind of
they might be calculating daily active
logins which is
the dirty game to play because it's the
one person logs into five different
accounts then it's still one person well
i mean look if they couldn't figure out
how many people were using their website
all i have to say is they need to learn
to code
that's a fair point i knew somebody was
gonna say that yeah we're waiting for it
yeah they do need to learn that but but
uh
i don't know what happens does anything
happen is i mean look we're seeing a lot
of victories across the board but does
anybody really believe someone will be
held accountable for this stuff i i
predict that there's going to be a lot
more that's going to come out of this
closet and twitter that this is going to
be less of the problem that i think
we're going to find out as far as what's
been being manipulated over the last x
amount of years well as we pointed out
earlier you know in the intro and the
other day this weird conspiracy theory
that i think is backed up by more than
enough circumstantial evidence to say
there should be a probe i believe there
should be a criminal investigation
because uh jack dorsey as well i i can't
remember who else but i'm pretty sure
other people from twitter have testified
before congress under oath i'm pretty
sure they're all under oath right yep as
saying they did not have political blocs
or anything like that
now we're seeing serious circumstantial
evidence that that was not true
of course
i'm not confident anybody would do
anything about it well during the
hacking when we were talking about the
day the blue checks disappeared there
was screenshots that were sent out that
showed there was a box to click for
shadow banding like that was a real
thing that got out that they kind of you
know whisked away and but there was a
lot of there's a lot of stuff that did
come up after that popped up that they
showed these screenshots um i mean the
bigger day was that it had been hacked
but then there were all of these
screenshots that popped up that there
was this this you know console that
showed uh
that there was an ability to kind of
quiet certain uses here's the game they
play though so if we if we go back to
2018 we have the story from end gadget
twitter's shadow banning bug unfairly
filtered 600 000 accounts jack dorsey
confirms this
they say you know our algorithms were
unfairly filtering six hundred thousand
accounts including some members of
congress from our search autocomplete
but how did it happen blah blah blah
blah blah you know what they would say
but it was not political but it is
the game they'll play is
right now uh elon musk he posted the
meme of me and vijaya gaday and it's
like the circle where it's like here's
left-wing bias
and a bunch of leftists were like is
misgendering really political they're
arguing that
purposefully dead naming someone is
political and i'm like it is
it is not a moral statement
conservatives do not agree with your
worldview and define things differently
it is inherently political
they don't accept that so they argue
it's not political so then they'll say
well we're talking about pronoun use has
nothing to do with politics right well
they're completely full of it they know
that referring to something is
non-political as just a useful
rhetorical tool so everything is
political exactly so they'll say
everything is political but then when it
comes to something they want to be taken
for granted they'll say this isn't
political human rights aren't political
it's like well actually the reason a
political system exists to a large
extent is for us to figure out on a
political scale how we treat each other
so yes it is but also most of these
mistakes that if you look back to over
the years that were happening just
coincidentally were happening to
conservatives i mean
you didn't see like sir uh sank and uh
all these giant liberals on the right on
the left you know their their accounts
being
shadow banned or losing people or being
for that matter being suspended for
anything
the the red-headed libertarian good
friend of ours josie that's her twitter
follow her at t r h l official
she was banned on january 20th
re of 2021 and reinstated abruptly this
year randomly on tuesday and she said
this has has this happened to any
prominent left-wing profile no
not a single one have anybody seen any
anybody look i follow people on the left
i interact with them i have not seen a
single person on the left be like whoa
my account was just brought back that's
so weird i've never met a person in the
left that had their account suspended
yeah everyone brought well
there are there were a handful of people
anti-war oh yeah well anti-war
anti-establishment leftists they got
nuked that's funny or people on the left
who were part of that rare breed that
actually spoke out against the coveted
restrictions right right
yeah the uh uh several people from
occupy wall street had their accounts
nuked and
i i think it was because what we're
really seeing is establishment versus
anti-establishment
and because
the people associated with the sphere of
influence of the right order we want to
call it our anti-establishment they're
more likely to get hit but there there
were so uh project veritas did an expose
and they found that um i think it's live
action is it's right live action that
would be lila rose's group yes they were
being censored by i think it was
pinterest
that's right but in that blacklist i
think it was pinterest in the blacklist
was also um anti-media i think it was
one of these anti-war groups that was
anti-media groups it was anti-media and
uh uh scott scott horton he's from uh no
it's he's entitled to war okay so the
anti-media guys are like fairly anti-war
and i said hey that's a big deal too
i think what's really happening is if if
you are in line with the establishment
they don't care in what capacity right
you're protected
so being pro-war
look at look at these conservatives i'm
doing air quotes who are staunchly
pro-war and align themselves with
democrats they're all fine yeah exactly
like i don't think liz cheney's going to
get shadow banned any time soon i don't
think anyone was ever concerned about
that for her
do you guys think that corporations
should be allowed to have blacklists
social media networks no well what do
you mean by that have like behind the
scenes uh lists that they can put you on
that why not change the way that you see
the network it depends on the network i
suppose i think the change has to come
once a platform reaches a certain size
so if if you have a blog that reaches a
hundred thousand people and it's like
you know a cowboy living blog and you
allow people to post their cowboy
stories i think it makes sense to be
like hey it can only be cowboy stuff but
if you have twitter which markets itself
to everyone
and it's open to all to have you know
the free speech wing of the free speech
party and then you start deciding no no
no at that point it's there's something
bad going on i mean there were rulings
that when trump was banning people when
he was president that he had to unban
them i think right there was a case so i
mean i think the courts are getting to a
point where the courts eventually are
going to weigh in on this that you know
a town square
certainly has a certain level of
protection that i think is kind of just
weight making its way through
the system but we'll get there yeah and
you know trump wasn't even banning
people he was just blocking that's why i
meant blocking no it's true but also we
were talking about this i believe two
episodes ago but that would be pretty in
line with the decision of martial
alabama again i'm no lawyer but it was
basically decided by the supreme court
in 1946 that even if you own a company
town and it's your own private property
if you open yourself up to the public
square to a large enough extent you have
to import the first amendment basically
or the civil rights that would be due to
the people in that jurisdiction
i think that makes sense
what about verizon
and verizon now phone companies yeah
public no it's if they're a common care
utility they shouldn't be allowed to do
that they should have to they should
have to provide service but you know
they do they play dirty games so a t
wouldn't let me open an account unless i
gave them cash up front
and i was like i have literally no i
don't want a t that bad i was you know
because um when we when when you when
you travel you want multiple networks so
uh particularly we have a cellular
bonding unit for one around the road
that combines a bunch of different cell
signals into one that we can do um
better broadcast stuff so i said the
best thing to do is to get multiple
networks to avoid congestion and at t
was like oh you can you can sign up here
but you got to give a 600 bucks up front
and then i was like you want me to give
you 600 bucks in cash right now just to
sign up and then what happens that money
we hold it like i don't need your
service dude but that's one thing they
do to block you so imagine imagine you
make 20 bucks an hour
can you afford to make a deposit that
large is what they do to poor people to
say we're not blocking them from the
service we just need a security deposit
which blocks them from the service i
don't think you would need a lot of
these laws and stuff if people that's
why i think when musk put that you know
the poll out do you feel that this is a
fair
and it was 70 no the free speech i think
most americans are kind of even keeled
and
they can see i think if both sides felt
that they were being treated fairly
there would be no problem that's not
possible right right and the the issue
is
i'd like you all to imagine something
imagine there is a big sphere of water
and there's a right side of it and a
left side of it at some point a small
bud started to emerge on the left side
and get bigger it got bigger and bigger
and bigger until it eventually butted
off and flopped onto the ground
that same sphere still has a left and a
right but now there's this new sphere
multicultural democracy staring at its
parent constitutional republic
so
that that budded sphere of influence
doesn't care for principles or morals it
wants power it wants to grow
it will never be satisfied so there's no
making it happen elon musk says he wants
everyone to be you know equally happy or
upset i'm like ain't gonna happen
usually when the buds fall off the trick
it's they get eaten by like a zebra who
walks away and poops it out somewhere
else that's how the trees spread their
seed so maybe that's i think it's
withering i think i think what we're
seeing now with twitter and panic with
these weird algorithmic changes with cnn
plus collapsing with joy reid losing her
job with uh with corden what's it james
corden quitting with all of these things
what we're seeing is that it can't
survive on its own it butted off but it
has no source of of energy and so people
like yuger and brian stelter and all
these people who decided to join that
sphere are now watching the walls close
in on them as it dries out as its life
energy is evaporating all around it
unable to sustain itself and they'll
regret it well i think it has to do with
also like ratings it's it's there has to
be anger
and a reason for people to come to
something and if you look at ratings on
msnbc versus cnn you know if there's a
giant terror attack you're guaranteed
that cnn's going to beat everyone
because people run to these things and i
think that
these types of these types of um
products
pull people towards it and you know
there was a giant people uh there were a
lot of people invented during the trump
era that fed off of the rage well so let
me let me pull up this next story from
the daily mail it's actually just a meme
elon musk hints he's shifted to the
right over the last 14 years no no daily
mail that is not what he's saying it's
hilarious as liberals morphed into woke
progressives he is not saying he shifted
to the right he's quite literally saying
he has not moved at all
in this image i believe it's a meme from
colin wright that's correct yeah that's
congratulations colin very cool uh he
posted him with me and now a meme of you
it is just a win winning week for us in
2008 you can see there's the right-wing
conservatives the left-wing liberals and
there's me left of center and it says my
fellow liberal in 2012 the left started
moving way further left and now me was
closer to the center because left and
right were spreading further apart by
2021
me the character in the comic has stayed
in the exact same place
but the left has gone so far left
that me is now closer to conservative
and you know what's funny elon musk elon
musk elon musk posted that i always mix
the next word up in elon musk elon musk
posted that and i said that perfectly
explains this show and me
we are not conservatives we have always
been uh well sheamus is conservative i'm
sure conservative definitely but i mean
like here like me personally and you
know the stuff i've been working on you
know i got started covering news and
media with occupy wall street i was i
was politically active writing punk
music and protesting war with all these
liberals voting for obama in 2008 and
then
throughout the next you know bernie
sanders
he was he was opposed to immigration he
said open borders with the koch brothers
proposal he wanted to help the working
class said gun rights was an urban
versus rural issue and i'm like i like i
like this guy he's been consistent he's
standing up for these things i can
respect that and then bernie decided to
run along with the left
as did so many other personalities and
they sacrificed any sense of principle
and conviction
for tribe so here i am standing in the
same place and now they're like your
right wing and i'm like that's exactly
my point
so you've got this memes posted and this
dude this guy max
verified twitter user posts it and says
the right literally tried to overthrow
the government the left nominated joe
biden and i'm like you're proving the
point
nearly every single right-wing person
condemned what happened correct on
january 6 said it was wrong some of
those prominent right-wing individuals
all said the violence was a big mistake
and they shouldn't have done it
you didn't just elect joe biden you are
pushing for
strange
secret sexual conversations among
children
you have now uh there there's outright
leftist policy like uh bernie sanders
wants 20 of corporations to be owned by
the workers
and you have my friends the green new
deal this is what i referenced i when if
you look at my my videos
it was back in 2018 i think
when aoc was talking about the green new
deal i said fantastic i love the idea
the government should be taking this tax
money and investing in wind farms you
know solar energy roads bridges let's
get the infrastructure built back up
because these bridges are crumbling we
can't live this way
aoc is finally about to announce the
green new deal and i'm like let's see it
and she goes free health care for black
people and i'm like okay wait hold on
all right you wanna have a conversation
about racial issues and
and you know
they say people of color
i'm down but what does this have to do
with wind farms so here i am actually
looking at environmental policy instead
what do we get critical race theory
so
i'm not taking away sheamus well no i
mean this is something we see the left
doing constantly you guys all know my
theory uh leftism is just a word that we
give to social decay things change very
quickly when they're breaking down so
you demolish a building it falls a lot
more quickly
than it took to put the thing together
in the first place of course there are a
lot of people who are considered to be
on the left who are now looked at as
right-wing figures and not only that but
far-right figures now i'm only 27 years
old and yet i am old enough to remember
when you had to be conservative in order
to be considered far right now you can
be a pretty middle-of-the-road moderate
typer even a soft liberal and be
considered far right i can straight up
be like well i for one think we need a
progressive tax and universal basic
health care and they're like he's far
right he's far right well it's just a
pejorative now it's just a label like
anything else to put you down call you a
racist far right and then people hope
after the first label you don't read
about what you're actually saying i like
that alt-right because like yeah what is
that is that up it's like it's
actually down below the new nazi you
don't have one right was the was the
kind of during during trump was
terminated
and the the the alt-right had a lot in
common with the woke left in terms of
their racial ideology so racism in fact
that's actually how the alt-right
explained it in many circumstances
that
it was actually uh expressed to me
that the alt-right is basically black
lives matter for white people yeah yeah
that white community movement
is exactly no no no no no no white
purity that's a bit much you know what
they were pride no no white pride what
they were literally saying it's okay to
be white
you can you can accuse them of secretly
believing whatever they want what many
of these guys were publicly saying was
white rights right they were like all
we're trying to do is make sure that you
know we have equal rights
and look you can call them liars but
that's what they were publicly stating i
had a lot of
moderate minds that i'd see a lot of
white purity stuff that was really
annoying that's totally different it was
i mean that's why
yeah but that's i think where the
alt-right came from is they thought that
that was this dangerous racist white or
racist movement but this
black lives matter is very similar i'm
not going to say the exact same thing
but no they don't like the general idea
which allowed the uh like literal
neo-nazis to recruit
was that they were going to young white
men who were frustrated for a variety of
reasons couldn't find work and they were
saying hey you see all those memes
all those news stories about how white
people are bad and evil doesn't that
frustrate you and make you angry
join us and they would say okay my
grievance has now been addressed yeah
it'd be a normal guy would be like okay
fine and then he'd make a post i would
say it's okay to be white and you'd be
like and then they'd be like oh he's
he's indicating racism this is a racist
movement you know and then the left it's
there's this kind of push on both sides
and then you know you make this symbol
this firefighter made and now he's away
national and there was this whole media
circus behind all of it that took you
know i'm sure there were plenty of you
know
white supremacist fringes in that
movement but the vast majority of them
were probably just guys saying i'm a
straight white guy
what's wrong with me
and then you get this pushback from the
left saying you're this that the other
thing and you make them more extreme
because you're continually trying to
one-up each other yeah i mean when you
look at how hard the left has to reach
and grasp its draws in order to conjure
up any kind of narrative of america
being a white supremacist country
basically all the hate crime narratives
we hear end up being completely false
upon further investigation they don't
hold up to the slightest scrutiny um
every single time they accuse someone of
being racism it's because they dog
whistled a dog whistle which was also a
dog whistle that could possibly have
some racist meaning behind that only
they could hear and somehow only
left-wing people but also you would hear
things like you know asian hate asian
hate asian hate and then you would you
know look further and it was a black guy
with an asian girl black guy black and
then you watched in the media that the
race which was just part of as being an
editor you would ask their age and
normally their race normally just
started to vanish so if it was a group
of five black kids it would just save
five people if it was five white men
doing something to somebody else you'd
see something especially with a white
guy going after an asian they would
always show that it was a white guy yeah
and then i found out that it was a lot
of fun
even more insidious i'm not sure if
y'all remember a couple of years ago
there were there was a group of
black young adults who kidnapped a white
young adult with autism and tortured him
for days and it was a consistent trend
that in media
they were referred to as kids and he was
referred to as a man right were they
even though they were all over the age
of 18. oh that's weird yep because and
it's the same thing whenever you have
any kind of racial narrative if the
white person is the victim and they're
attacked by another minority group or a
minority group um then the race is left
out of it but
if there's a minority being attacked by
a white person of course the racial
identity is front and center ethnic
identity it's front and center in the
report it feels like there's a very
small minority of vocal racists that
were like white supremacist racists that
use social media to amplify it and then
there's a very small minority of black
supremacists these people that are like
trying to run the black racist movement
and we're caught in the middle most
people are and they're like what in the
hell but then it starts to seep into the
politics and then you're like oh god we
gotta let me take control of our
government i want to pull this tweet
from nate silver he says folks it's not
that hard the left has moved to the left
in the u.s and the right has moved to
the right what that's not true no pew
research actually tracked and um i think
they did this based on the language used
by both parties yes
it is plain to see
the right has moved a little bit to the
right okay fine fair point the left has
gone completely off the rails
so when from where i'm standing i can't
even see where the left is i'm like what
are they doing i look up to my right and
i'm like oh there's a guy who doesn't
believe in gay marriage i'm like but but
that's recognizable to me i disagree but
i've seen that before the difference
as a gay man let me just tell you that
the the difference was
in the past if you weren't against gay
marriage
that was fine
you know that was one thing now the left
has to destroy you
for that view that's how so the old left
would just be like you know give them a
chance it's not going to change your
life and now they're finding out where
you work so they can tell your bloss
your homophobe that's the from a gay
man's point of view
who looks at all this insanity and sees
that i've seen that change where you
could just disagree like say i don't
think that i think it's a traditional
thing that you know man and a woman go
have your civil unions
fine
the liberal in the audience would be
just like oh you know you should really
think that over now the liberal in the
audience gets on twitter tells them who
you are and has you fired and that's
how far the left have gone with these
types of and you can pick any topic and
they'll do the same thing
i do believe that the
right has gone further right it's just
been banned off of social media because
i i had to administer these people on
mines like i saw them exodus from
twitter youtube and facebook and like
they were very extreme yeah i think
what's happened is when i think i hate
to keep saying trump all the time but
when he came along
an industry popped up where you had this
disinformation in fact for some reason
we had social media for years that
didn't need fact checkers cnn was from
the 80s and didn't have a
front focal fact checker that needed to
come out every 10 minutes dale and tell
you what he was right that's what the
journalist was supposed to do and i
think what happened over the years was
that the highlighting of these terrible
things um
were amplified and so an event occurred
there was six people now there's white
nationalism and then trump must like
that and then all the just like
if you're a conservative today then you
agreed that people should burn down the
capital i mean that's where we are in in
your discord these days if you're
conservative or you voted for trump then
you think that the riots were fine and i
wanna i wanna i wanna point out another
big issue in all of this too and i have
this pew research democrats and
republicans more ideologically divided
than in the past and we can see 9404
2014
this is the chart that's often cited by
many people there's another one that
updates it and it shows a later year i
think 2018. you can see in this chart at
the very least that in the 90s democrats
and republicans overlapped greatly in
2004 they did quite a bit republicans
had a bit more by 2014 the democrats
have moved much further left and the
republicans have moved to the right you
can see by looking down here at the
bottom right
now the democrats jumped i think like
three or four points to the left and the
republicans have moved like one or two
here's the fascinating thing nate silver
has another bit of data from pew
research saying the exact opposite this
killed me this shows the democrats
staying static and the republicans going
to the far right but nate silver also
said hillary was going to win
but these are these are both from pew
research right so what will happen is
nate silver chooses this and says oh see
the republicans went far right and then
what did we just cite a moment ago i
cited the data saying the opposite so i
just i throw this in the garbage i'll
tell you this the only real change i've
had in my politics is gun rights
i used to be kind of middle of the road
like yeah maybe there could be some gun
control and now i'm like no gun control
everybody gets 50 bmgs
everything else is basically the same
mine's social medicine i used to be all
about it but now i see these people that
just eat crappy food and refuse to stop
i'm not gonna pay for them right yeah i
mean
no one with any sense can take a chart
like that seriously it's just something
that left-wing people believe in because
they buy into all the hate hoaxes they
hear from the media and they genuinely
believe that america has become a
fascist country because donald trump was
elected fairly in 2016. we did a video
about this for freedom tunes where we
debunked a similar analysis that carl
carlos mazza was using and so we sort of
went through and pulled it apart but
in order to get figures like this
the one that we debunked specifically
which i'm sure uses a similar
methodology basically put obama and
harry truman on the same level with
respect to how far to the left they were
anyone who knows anything about history
or either of those men will tell you
that that's absolutely ridiculous and
you mentioned earlier that obama is on
the right technically speaking or
according to the the analysis you
brought up earlier he was the most
far-left president we had ever had up
until the point when he was elected he
campaigned on universal healthcare not a
dramatic and complete overhaul of our
health care system to the left that was
substantial and as a senator in illinois
he voted against the born alive act
which would prevent you from being able
to kill the child after they were born
if the abortion failed let's let's let
me address this tweet from sawyer
hackett who responded nate silver sawyer
is a blue check coast of our america
podcast and he says the left healthcare
should be free i think the right
washington is run by a cabal of child
trafficking pedos and we should
violently overthrow
both sides am i right well let's break
this down
the left is some people who think
healthcare should be free but would that
include me
well i just said i think we should have
universal basic healthcare i say that
all the time no it doesn't include me i
also don't think washington is run by a
cabal of child trafficking you know
whatever i think that's just corrupt
people doing corrupt things i do think
people like epstein have uh a strange
amount of influence among powerful
global elites but that's a fact
so what is he really referring to what
they're doing is either they're
completely blind or they lie as a means
to an end
when they say by any means necessary
when they smash windows when they kill
when they lie cheat and steal and then
they look at a group of you know 800 or
so people who violently write it at the
capitol and we sit here and say that was
wrong they shouldn't have done that
those who are violent will go to prison
they ignore that outright
when they lie and make up things about
the parental rights and education bill
they this is the game they play
now there are people on the right who
play similar game for sure but at look
i'm approaching this from i read
different news sources i use ground.news
and look at the bias and ownership of
these news outlets they can show you if
it's conglomerate private interest they
can tell you if it's left-leaning or
right-leaning and what i find is that on
the right
for whatever reason someone like ben
shapiro one of the most prominent
conservative personalities whether or
not people like him he's very famous
with one of the biggest podcasts in the
country nate the world
and he is a very moderate conservative
guy he's not far right he's got your
traditional conservative positions and
he bases his assessments on fact
on the left you have people like rachel
maddow who for years said insane things
about russia jenk yuger who just called
for intervention in ukraine because he
thinks russians are staging waging this
war because they want to kill gay people
you have people like joy reid who didn't
she claim that she was attacked yes went
but did they debunk that no she wasn't
hacked she had written all these
anti-gay homophobic things and then you
know she was going to get investigated
and then that vanished and lies oh yeah
let me let me go through shall we go
through the lies again i mean do we
really have to keep doing this list we
only have like an hour and a half i know
i don't know if you can kyle rittenhouse
the daily beast has now been rated as
caution fake news i'm adding the fake
news but caution you know very big
violation of journalistic ethics by
newsguard
and it's primarily because everything
they report on cal right now was wrong
and they refuse to correct it
that's the left that is the
establishment and it is the people who
are like you know you've got these
leftist personalities who are like well
i don't like the democrats i'm on the
left but you all should vote for joe
biden
joe biden is a corrupt authoritarian and
these people supported him so spare me
at the very least i can explain donald
trump he's a bull rampaging through the
ivory tower don't like him and the
things he does that's fine he was a bull
rampaging through the ivory tower i
could i could accept that but i like
some of his policies they play this game
where they they're obtuse on purpose or
they're genuinely just broken people
well they also in the media they'll
they'll just
leave facts out
and
they do look the covington kids you can
go down the list of things and if you
own the shop like they do they're not
going to report it and they've they've
lived through this whole existence where
they're not used to being called out and
they
you know
roger ale said to me once about you know
and he's famously said to it in in
public that you know there's 30 liberal
sites and
organizations on the left and there's
just us and they can't they lose their
mind over us and it's because they call
fox like the canary in the coal mines so
you notice if you've watched fox and god
only knows i lived my life doing this
for a living which was
they've been talking about the border
for months and months and months and now
all of a sudden you start to see this
creep into cnn and title 42 and what are
we gonna do and you're like if you've
been watching fox you've heard about it
since you know last year when they were
coming across the border so the media
has famously when it comes to writing
about the left or the right they will
picking it's the gay you know the gay
don't say gay bill you know nothing in
the bill said gay and yet it's if you
looked at the headlines they just copied
and pasted off they went
just because you know i've worked in
newsrooms it's a bunch of 20 year old
people afraid
to not go on a date and it's a bunch of
old editors who are afraid to get yelled
at on twitter or afraid to not go on a
date
afraid to afraid that they won't you
know if you have a bunch i've seen it in
conservative new rooms in dc where you
still have young people who are quote
unquote conservatives but they are very
in tune to what people are saying to
them about them on twitter because they
have to live in this liberal city and so
it affects you know it affects
you know what we're seeing with
everything is fierce ability to come
back at people like you know you do and
other people they you know you will say
what you mean and not worry about it
whereas you have so many people who are
terrified because they see what happens
to people they get canceled i mean you
know this libs of ted talk comes out
there and just basically just rewrites
what people not saying you didn't change
the video yeah it's like hillary's
emails nothing of those emails were made
up that's what they said you know let
people read them and all these people
are crazy but the libs of tick tock was
a perfect example she has a million
followers now because of these people
but they're so threatened by just but
all it did was bring and take the filter
out of the media because you think the
media is going to go look at what people
are saying about kids being taught this
or that in school because those are the
facts take a look at this story from
2019
when did barack obama become a
republican oh boy i don't know how about
this one from the washington post
november 22 2019 barack obama
conservative
yeah so when they're like the right has
moved to the right and also barack obama
who's in favor of universal health care
is a conservative and republican
y'all have lost the plot i'm sorry
there's not even a point to reading
through this stuff at this point well
here's the thing barack obama is not to
the left as the niche far-left ideology
that like some 16-year-old on twitter is
posting about therefore he's on the
right
right
all right i can't contribute because i
don't know what the right and the left
are anymore donald trump was a liberal
guy that ran for the republican party
tribe it's tried i guess so and
depending on where you're standing red
feelings
i think it's like i think it's a
community i think people but trump trump
was the guy i said this before when you
were the
boomer me or
gen x yelling at the tv he yelled back
for years they would scream at the tv
about immigration or something and for
once a politician actually yelled back
at them and they heard them like
somebody heard me yelling and they went
out in droves i friends up in
massachusetts who were staunch liberals
who were like you know what
i'm gonna vote for him because i've seen
hillary and i don't want that but he
speaks to me now you know ten years ago
as a conservative you know you'd be
thrown out if you even a hint that you
cheated on your wife
and now that's fine because people were
so sick of being talked down to
that you know the fly over states and
this and that that he he hit a nerve in
people and everyone you know the people
voted for him remember him in the 80s
they weren't you know they remember
vodka they remember that whole show of a
mess that took place in his life they
knew it wasn't going to be pretty
but they wanted to blow that city up and
you know it blew up the media him
everyone around him and you know it
changed america forever you mentioned
some of the misdeeds in trump's personal
life the left spent years telling us
that we shouldn't care how a person
conducts themselves in their private
life what we should care about are the
policies policies they support as if a
political leader is just a set of
policies and not a person who has to
make moral decisions by the people that
they're committed to and then trump
comes along and he absolutely did not
follow the rules that i uh as a
christian and many conservatives would
say that a political leader should but
he didn't hate us he didn't absolutely
detest us like virtually every other
political leader of my lifetime has and
so conservatives said you know what
we'll take this guy and the left went
but don't you care about his personal
life didn't didn't he call rosie
o'donnell a fat pig
and everyone was laughing and screaming
and cheering and yeah i mean you know he
he said things that a lot of people
thought and it was people you know he
you're right he he didn't he's a
billionaire who should look down from
his tower but for whatever reason if you
talk to these people especially people
at the i went some of these these events
with him
and it was like a god showed up because
it it's a lot of people who spent a lot
of years caring about the country and
watching it tick away and somebody now
he was flawed and you can say what you
want about him but his heart was at
least in the right place from their
point of view and you know we need the
americans want to be involved in the
political processes they should be in
the president's their our
representatives so for a president to
respond to you and allow themselves to
be changed by your opinions that's the
point well i think he embodied that and
that's why a lot of people really like
donald trump
i also i also want to mention this on
the point of his personal life and his
private life it's not exist it's not as
if we just had this abundance of very
well conducted moral people to choose
from first president of the united
states like you didn't have the most
moral person who would ever live running
next to donald trump hillary's trump
versus hillary clinton right i see that
in the republican primaries it was like
trump first a bunch of swamp creatures
right
for the most part not all of them but i
when i saw hillary in 2016 i just
laughed i was like you think i'm gonna
vote for that you're insane
this lady was like
warmonger of war mongers but she but the
first female president oh and you know
what she doesn't believe all women if
you're not monica lewinsky let me pull
up this next story here so i've got some
good news let's
talk about where we're heading cnn plus
to cease on thursday two days earlier
than announced cnn plus couldn't even
fail on schedule right oh that's
wonderful that is brutal well this is a
this is a big change i mean cnn put uh
300 million i believe into it right yes
and you know the the story behind it is
uh you know
somebody i know at discovery called it
uh uh
an ego project basically a zucker ego
project and it was tossed in by the guy
who left there kind of as a we wanted
this we're going to do it you're stuck
with it and i don't think anyone thought
that they were just going to shut it
down because you know
that's a pretty big move to bring over
chris wallace and so forth wow i had
reported that when chris got over there
he was you know having people count
like interns count how many times he was
furious because you know the staff was
different it wasn't as big of an
operation his ego
one of the little secrets is like most
of these anchors hate each other like
there's very few people like don lemon
and and cuomo you just have these little
chit chats but boy when cuomo left lemon
couldn't talk about him bad as fast as
he could and you know like famously
wallace and uh tu and tapper
hate each other
the problem was when zucker left he left
this giant vacuum of power because he
was hands-on
and you know the thought that and my old
boss dan abrams did a thing once right
when this launch was like who thought
this would be a good idea
like who thought you wanted to watch and
tucker like somebody said to me and i
was kind of invested but not super was
like you know that tapper has a book
show on this i'm like a book show we're
gonna listen to him talk about books on
streaming and i remember thinking to
myself that can't be true
and there it was and you know
i've been in the media 15 years and
there's this not only is there a city
bubble in new york and d.c there's also
a media bubble within them that they
think
that they live in this moment and they
live in these big
important roles and you if you try to
question their judgment or or disrupt
their judgment on how things should work
and you know you know it's kind of like
when facebook years ago said pivot to
video and all these companies spent
millions of dollars spending on video
equipment then nothing happened because
i guess millennials wanted 15 second
videos not 30 second videos but this was
you know we need a streaming service
because the kids are watching streaming
and most people think to themselves it
had to be like a lot of focus groups and
stuff yeah they paid money to be told
that this would work
when if you asked a person on the corner
would this homeless person who had a
bearer in like had watched cable in the
last five years would say god no he
wouldn't you know he'd you know but they
did good did they not do they did a
study from and i can't remember whether
it was kpmg and i don't want to but it
was one of the big ones that said this
will be x amount of x whatever now to be
fair when when zucker came on
when he took over he introduced
documentaries now you look at cnn today
and you think wow they have some pretty
good documentaries
and people made fun of him when he did
that so he's had some good ideas let's
just say that if they had endless
amounts of money and endless amounts of
time maybe once no one had cable anymore
and this was the only way to watch cnn
it might have worked but when discovery
comes in and has you know x amount of
billions of dollars in debt and this
thing is costing and you know wallace is
making seven million i mean that's what
they they're paying him oh yeah oh
absolutely had to be about worth every
time seven to ten million dollars
because
that's about what lemon and those people
make now the odds are that waltz is
probably going to end up with cuomo's
own time slot at nine right because you
got this guy what are you gonna do with
them he's a good brand
the problem with him when i reported
this he has no beach head both sides
hate him equally like the left had him
because he was near fox the fox people
hit him because he couldn't just be
quiet and leave he he had to you know
poop on tucker and and the left and they
don't you know they remember this
and so he's kind of this island of
people who but but i heard that the new
the new leadership wants to purge cnn
political stuff so it's happening if
you've just if you're a casual watcher
and watch say brian stelter who right
now is kind of this thing to watch as
far as the tempo there he's the guy who
used to every sunday go after fox or
tweet at fox or say this stuff about he
hasn't said anything about fox because
they kind of set the rules where this
isn't about this is the news
organization this isn't about going
after another news organization this is
about
you know and then the ukraine the
ukraine stuff happened perfect timing
for the people in discovery who wanted
to see cnn go back to news because they
do an excellent drug call this award and
all these people or bombs going after
him it reminds
the only people who are watching cable
boomers
of you know bernie in iraq when you know
we for the first time saw a war happen
live during shock and awe so it kind of
reinforced that there is a business
there now the problem with that is no
one's watching cable news anymore and
unless it's a crazy moment happening
people aren't running to the tvs and god
only know you guys in your 20s aren't
sitting there watching cable on your pa
if you even have a cable tv package it
used to be that when i heard on i saw
that sound yeah when i saw a tweet and
it said thing happened i would turn on c
right i don't do that anymore right
fox and they like but but also that
whole breaking news thing used to be
when there was breaking news now fox has
it every commercial and it's kind of
lost its luster where you used to hear
that noise and something big was
happening
but this will be probably one of the
largest media disasters for i hope for
hundreds of years from now i mean it's
the epic size of this you can't even
begin to
there's there's part of me that likes
would like to believe that the people at
cnn putting the project together saw the
market research that showed it wouldn't
work they're like hold on let's just
send it to snopes first let's see let's
see if they can debunk this research
telling us it's not going to work again
you can't imagine the egos at play
and you
you know they live in now hudson yards
this gigantic building on this island
with looking down at people and they all
talk to each other they all go to the
same places they all you know are all
above everyone else and you know the
lack of failure and they just can't
figure out why physics works but this
cnn plus is the perfect example of the
information cnn presents itself correct
they live in a bubble where they're all
farting and then rushing over to smell
the person's fight and telling everybody
it smells like it's i call it naval
gazing and it's if you go to these
parties you'll see like i'll tell you
one thing working at meteorite the best
thing that ever happened was the cnn
launch parties when they launched this
thing i don't know what the number is
but it was hundreds of thousands of
dollars for the launch party of this
giant logo
giant logo but no it's just all of the
media people come from all the different
media places that's why you know fox is
the out loud outlier but you'll all see
them with each other at different
parties and it's all this little club
they're in and they all know each other
and they've all worked with each other
that's why you see media reporters that
you know will always you know kind of
hedge what they're going to say because
they're thinking well who knows what
they're going to own someday and i might
want to work for them
wouldn't it be hysterical if you turn on
cnn they're like cnn plus is doing great
yeah i know it's awesome well they did
the best network ever
are you kidding me
matt dornick the the oh the
communication strategist
he's a conservative gay guy who
was kind of invented for trump because
the cnn pr used to be the kindest
sweetest people
like if they working on the other end of
it when they didn't like something it
would be this nice email and they got
matt
to just become this bulldog that was
basically the trump version of a pr
person at cnn but anyway he famously
said it was doing great and they were
hoping and then it went out of business
like two days later cnn plus yeah so
matt dorney this is a funny story here
it was pointed out that joe biden is not
a practicing catholic because by
definition he is and he doesn't give a
sent to catholic teaching and so someone
reached out to cnn
explaining this cnn you call joe biden a
practicing catholic he is not that is a
factual error you should correct it matt
dornick screenshots the email and tweets
it out saying this is really gross which
personally personally speaking i don't
think it's a great communication
strategy it's like screenshots someone's
email and then he posted it calling it
gross but also he comple he dismissed a
blatant like clear-cut fact yeah he's
he's kind of the representation of what
happened to cnn at in the trump era in
that it was all they felt the only way
to respond to him is become what see
they viewed him as just this ignorant
loud buffoon and what they ended up
becoming was the ignorant loud buffoon
like
um i the chris wallace news makes me
feel really good like
what's what's
yeah yeah no and
he was fine until
you know he left people like megan kelly
when she left she went to nbc now i love
megyn kelly and
but everyone knew you know you are what
fox be makes you your audience isn't
going to go to nbc in the morning that
was weird but she ended up with 30
million extra bucks in the bank because
they because she she said something
offensive about again she was black
santa and then said something she was it
wasn't even offensive no but it was like
why is that offensive and they're like
you don't know but they think they just
wanted an example no no no everyone
knows it was everyone knew it was a
pylon she knew it was a pile on that's
why she got paid and off she went and
now she did didn't they they initially
did was it the first the morning show
with megan yeah well she had the morning
shows she was like dancing yeah she then
she said this
thing uh she asked why was blackface
offensive why was blackface offensive
it's you're a new she should be in jail
no but you're a newspaper she belongs in
prison so you know that's the point like
what's the question you can't ask
anymore is how the news is made not what
should you like there's no more like
chris wallace's father mike wallace
you'd be scared out of your wits when he
walked in the doors because there was
nothing there was you know no agenda
with him now of course they were all
left-leaning but still you know
we've come in
we are in a period where it's the words
you're not allowed to say you know it's
the words there's a there's a like why
do gay people get a month like if i'm a
reporter and i went into the
headquarters of gay incorporated
why did you get a month
like
what happened why does everyone have to
change their logos and except for in the
middle east
and why are you okay with that china
yeah and why you know and you can't show
you know dr strange's new movie and then
in there because as a gay character does
that bother you nope you can't it's like
where did lgbtq plus a z where did that
come from well you can't ask those
questions correct well but i i will say
i thought it was strange that they moved
megan kelly from what was it fox news
primetime yeah to nbc morning shows like
a family woman-oriented thing and it's
it's what happens to media people it's
they you know and
i love her to death i love them all but
they you know you lose your mind you
become so famous that you think it's all
about that yes that's what cnn plus is
but let's let's let's talk about some
other uh good news some other some other
good news here well you're pulling this
up can i just mention something to his
earlier point so you said that cnn was
kind of trying to do this tough guy
thing and mimic trump and i i noticed a
little bit of that and i think it's
funny because a they clearly
misunderstood it's not just that people
like that trump was a tough guy they
liked who he was going after but even in
the example i brought up of of matt
dornick going this is really gross
that's not a tough guy thing to say no
that's not can you imagine trump going
this is really gross quite frankly no
you would actually go after the person
right they didn't know how to do it
so let's pull up this next story because
it's good news um actually john do you
want to explain what's going on with
this so
i reported this and you know the media
people are all like oh she's going
nowhere
well not officially yet but
comcast doesn't like her the people
roberts and the people at the top don't
like her and i got wind of something
that was said that you know
they're going to use and i said this to
somebody that if you notice the last few
days you saw her ratings being leaked
out as far as she's had the lowest
ratings and whatever but she's just
becoming offensive to everyone and it's
becoming offensive to advertisers
there's a lot of advertisers who are
balking you know there's only so many
times you can say that you know elon
musk bought it because he wants
apartheid back like you can say that
white people did x y and z but if you
just start using it as an example for
everything
you just you start to become offensive
to mostly even even black people find
her offensive many of my black friends
you know find many people i've talked to
find her offensive she's
she does comparable to don lemon but
that's not saying much yeah well
neither of those people are probably
going to be around for the
long term i mean take a look at this
this is uh tuesday's ratings
in the key demo this is
fascinating
joy with 130 000
uh against burnett with 170 anderson
cooper with 170 don lemon with 136 and
then 116. jake tapper with 140 and 159
blitzer 152
that's remarkable
because we do better than that
oh absolutely now you look you look at
waters 368. look at carlos oh yeah it's
not even 591. i've looked at these
ratings for 15 years and nothing changes
fox stays where it is and msn and you
know for a long time cnn wanted to be
msnbc because they were beating them and
then they decided no that's two to the
left and then trump came along and you
can't be what you're not wasn't tucker
carlson on msnbc no he was on cnn he
used to be a cnn show yeah he was but he
was on msnbc yes oh yeah yeah i mean
if you combine anderson cooper from cnn
and um chris hayes and msnbc you combine
their ratings it is still almost 300 000
viewers less than
it's not even a contest
you know there's media reporters who
keep asking like at msnbc they're giving
rachel maddow millions of dollars to do
nothing she does one show a week now and
now has special projects good for her
because yeah because they don't know
what to do with her what happened with
jury reads a fun story and that it
revolves a lot around
what happened with george floyd and it's
a basic narrative and that is they're
you know you al sharpton's those types
of people who have used race as a way to
continue to make money
and
she used it as a way to keep her job
because everyone at msnbc is terrified
of her and everyone at nbc universal is
terrified of her on the other hand
people at comcast who see now there's
also other things coming and speaking of
someone we've talked about earlier
there's lawsuits coming about things she
has said about people and and so forth
and we saw what happened with the
covington kids as far as you know how
that went before cnn and others and she
has said some things equal about people
that are coming down the pike all in all
she's just not up a positive light for
the network and they're she's made and
that whole gay thing
has come back to haunt her in ways that
i don't think she's quite well you can
never survive on the left man would see
you're okay if you're on the if you're
on the left and you say something like
that you're like oh it was hacked okay
move on if you're on the right they
would want to see the forensics of it
before you'd get your show back and
that's sort of part of my concern with
what we were discussing earlier about
elon musk potentially unveiling some
sketchiness or potential fraud with
twitter's code is that i think it would
end up being the same kind of stories we
got with hillary's emails everyone would
know that there was foul play and
nothing would be done about it and it
would just sort of be waved away i do
also want to mention however that when
we're looking at wallace's numbers
tappers numbers uh even maddow's numbers
i'm honored to say that i once did a
cartoon that was a parody of a news show
and it was literally just people farting
and it got more views
than they did of course and it was
called the dangers of political
extremism
this is important this is the key demo
we're not winning against cnn when it
comes to
old people no so if you look uh this is
this is uh what do we got here 25 to 54.
for us i believe around 80 percent of
our viewers are 18 to 54. their average
viewer is 68. 69. so you look at this
cnn when you do all viewers they say 25
to 54 rest assured cnn is not getting
500 600 000 viewers from 18 to 24. right
and there's no more airport video of
them so these are people probably in
institutions or places they can't change
the channel because i don't know any 18
year olds watching cnn yeah i want to
see what their engagement is because
they just have the tv show they have a
tv on from four o'clock to 10 o'clock
and they just let it run when they're in
the other room how old is uh rachel
maddow
she's got to be in her late 40s or 50s
by now it's it's a it's a yeah you've
got a pulper
and and uh how old is tucker
tucker's
50s hey something matt was born in 1973.
so she's
47 40. it's really quite amazing um
it's a strange it's a strange thought
for me the people who typically are like
yo hey i know who you are you're tim
poole when they greet me on the street
or whatever same it ages me of course
millennials uh often a lot of people who
look like they're mid to late 20s i
couldn't imagine being someone like
maddow and you go outside and young
people don't know who you are and then
you see some old person like hey you're
rich man i'm a big fan so it's either
like the super view of your cartoon
[Laughter]
i bet it's a girl with the pink hair and
the purple hair will come up to her or
people who are invested in the
now in the script even those far lefties
though even those progressive types who
are just completely wrong about
everything even they don't like legacy
media i watch twitch streamers who have
a left-handed perspective that's that's
true like you know hassan
young people are going to know who he is
i know who he is
tucker carlson with nearly 600 thousand
in the key demo yeah he's going to go
outside and young people are going to be
they know who
they know who he is they know he is
because he speaks to people like he
speaks you know you guys have to take on
the rest of this world and i think he
speaks to people who care about what's
happening in the country and i think you
know mata gets incredible she got her
ratings were
fox-esque during certain like the whole
uh you know mueller report
those types of things where people and
that shows you where we are as a country
because they're watching as a sporting
event they want their team trump to go
down they want him muller to come up and
say i got him and that's all they're
watching for yeah she almost she almost
cried oh yeah
well famously
mediate
i'm not sure you can see it on the side
anymore but
a famous abc journalist cried the night
that trump got elected
um and and he called her out later um
in in one of the first times he met them
but yeah there was a lot of people
invested i mean that night was surreal
just of how many people were sad
something happened in like 2015 to 2016
you know in this period where people's
brains just subtract it well it was that
moment it was like ben what's his name
outside the hillary event ben rhodes
where he's just sitting there that video
of him just sitting there going i i
don't know what happened it's a famous
video right after she gives her a
concession speech and he's just like
blindsided and and it's famous because
no one really knew what to say because
one side of you were like wow i voted
for him but do you think he's good
insane and the other side of you was
like yeah you know and
i watched a lot of young people feel
really happy about the future and you
know plus i think the mood of the
country was they were sick and tired
of the establishment i want to mention
this too it's not just joy reid james
corden is quitting the late late show
yeah yo the machine is falling apart
well also late night shows used to be
funny and now they're just political hit
jobs that's well yeah it's claptor and
there's so many colbert colbert coming
up on his show and saying hey hey
republicans are bad yeah
it's like that's not a joke dude i'm not
laughing or him doing the vaccine dance
thing these people have gone nuts i mean
look late night is just by definition a
really disadvantaged formula because a
good stand-up comedian might come out
with an hour every year and then these
late night hosts come out they're what
every night with something like 45
minutes of material and so it's not
going to be the best for the most part
even if you have talented writers but
they've stopped trying to be funny
altogether and it literally is just
clapter like you mentioned they always
used to be an escape you'd watch
showing my age johnny carson and these
other people and i remember you'd hear
his joke about nixon or something but
then he'd get on and people don't watch
these shows to hear about how bad the
republicans are and you know it's the
softest street it is
the the jimmy kimmel why is he having
political debates with people like
marjorie taylor green on his show yo can
you
hold on guys uh um moon knight came out
right it's it's a marvel show here's tim
marvel memeing no no but i mean this is
all i mean disney's got new shows um why
don't you come out and be like you guys
see that new show there's a new movie
with northmen and everyone can clap and
cheer for alex skarsgard and he can make
a joke about it i would say that if you
were conspiracy theorist you would say
that there's a media apparatus that
feeds off of itself if you ever listen
to what colbert says at night he's kind
of picking up on what the theme of the
day was for them going after
whoever
marjorie taylor green so she's the the
pinata for the left for the day and he
kind of finishes it off at the end of
the day and he they used to do that in a
funny way him and
jon stewart's a perfect example and he's
been in the news lately where he went
completely crazy left the other day
where he used to be
i mean he'd be he if you look at some of
his older shows he's gonna be a
conservative considered today he used to
be moderate in the middle and he would
grab everyone and you joke about some
idiot saying something so even the
republicans would be funny
and now you feel as though he knows that
he has to do these things to survive or
he will be you know canceled just like
nancy pelosi is afraid aoc is going to
cancel her but these people are
sad no they are sad
because
you know what young people want
authenticity correct old people i guess
fine john
you know you looked at some market
research and they said john i'm telling
you you got to go woke and be as racist
as you can against white people right
and then john's like i'm gonna do it and
then the rest of us are just like what
happened to that guy right he lost his
audience that elon musk mean let me let
me let me pull that meme back up look at
this this image right here this me in
the middle that's john stewart's fan
base right no straight up jon stewart
praised project veritas he mocked him a
little bit in funny ways like making fun
of james's clothing but said journalists
where are you look who's scooping you
how did these guys pull it off and then
he used their reporting legitimately not
ironically the acorn investigation
correct i like that i remember when he
came out in his pimp outfit for the
first time when he did his first show on
fox news i remember it to this day and
we did this whole write up about him and
you've watched as he's you know and
you're listening to a google employee or
whoever he happens to be getting a cnn
employee producer saying yeah we lean
left and the next day somehow that isn't
what you just saw and that's what's
happening is i think the autistic i
think people that are young
know this is all bs
you know what it is it's that people
like john stewart bringing in an
audience who doesn't pay attention to
the news right and then he says things
and the applause sign lights up right
and everyone's like
and they used to be interview shows up
until 2006 the only way you're going to
see an actor talk about their experience
was on the tonight show or letter right
or something like that now they have
their own youtube channels so i don't
need that crap junk now they're just
trying to fill the void right with
political and they have to say something
they have to
crap on trump it's just like the
award shows i mean
you used to go to those for escapism and
now you know whatever is happening in
the media as far as politics on the on
the right you're just and then there was
the gay gay gay thing this time where
you know there was this gay bill and you
know everyone had to say gay gay gay um
and i think mo and you see the ratings
like
do you not see what you're doing no
one's watching you anymore because
they're they're tired it's exhausting
but it's but it's not true that's that's
the issue it's like when they're going
out and screaming gay everyone's like
why are you doing that right jank yuger
of the young turks he tweets out
conservatives claim to be pro free
speech but they literally celebrate a
bill called don't say gay and i'm like
bro the bill's not called that right and
he's like yeah well you don't speak out
against desantis for his anti-bds
legislation i was like we mentioned
almost every time we talk about desantis
we say it was bad moving on i tweeted
and
i said i think the gay don't say gabriel
might be the largest
fastest fake news in history because
if you were to look at it that day every
single headline started with don't say
gay bill and no one i had in this famous
fight with mark hamill i said did you
read the bill i had thousands of people
like coming at me you know because no
one read the bill you don't think mark
hamill read six pages of this bill it
just says you can't and then you're like
if you're gonna pick a topic and as a
gay person trust me that came out in 88
we have a lot of things that we had to
overcome if you're gonna pick arguing
over whether a k through third grades
can talk about sex you're you're gonna
i've said this in in
sully um what's his name said it too
um you're gonna set the whole cause back
25 years because i've seen a lot of
homophobic stuff flow out since then now
everyone's this or that or pedophile or
that let's let's make this easy for
people who aren't familiar
i have no problem with critical race
theory books in schools i mean that
physically i have a problem with
critical race practice in schools that
is in curriculum when teachers put
critical race theory in practice
in their lessons now if a school said
hey kids here we have the bible and here
we have kimberly crenshaw's critical
race theory we're going to analyze and
discuss these ideas i'd like that's cool
when they come out they don't do that
though what they actually do now is they
say the bible can't be in the school at
all but don't worry there's no critical
race theory here we just put those
lessons in the curriculum now imagine
this imagine if
your kid went to school one day and he
came back with homework and the homework
said
jesus had 12 apostles one apostle
betrayed him how many apostles did not
betray him you'd be like well hold on
face
but but that's like the math problem
right it's it's a math question what is
that on the third day jesus rose 24
hours are in one day how many hours did
it take that would be
praxis taking the teachings of religion
but putting it in math lessons right now
religious schools actually do this and
that's fine if you go to a religious
school in a public school i don't think
she'd have critical practice or
religious praxis but if the teachers
want to discuss any ideology i'm fine
with it i think the one good thing that
came out of the pandemic is that parents
figured out what their kids were
learning in school like you were just
off the kid goes and i mean these days
hoping you didn't get shot but you just
off they went and then
now you get to look over their shoulder
while they're teaching these things and
i think it was a good and you saw it in
virginia you saw that was the meltdown
yeah you saw that parents you don't
screw with the kids and i'll tell you
you know there was a lot of democrats
who voted for him because
democrats love telling you how to run
your life until they have to you know
do it to their kids and uh we got to see
the what happens when you do that
because you know you can't make everyone
out to be trump uh you know i want to
mention on the parental rights and
education chat or uh bill i saw
something in the chicken city chat a
couple days ago and i wish i could
remember the username to attribute it to
them but they said it's not don't say
gay it's wait till they're eight
which is
so much more of an accurate way of
describing the bill and also helps you
understand that it doesn't even go far
enough right well so this is um you
don't want to get the guy too much
attention but
to respond to jake euger because he
tweeted back at me
saying you guys love to claim the name
as they said or otherwise but it
perfectly describes the bill i'm like
the bill bans discussions of traditional
marriage it's just insane
that they conflated uh a bill that was
trying to prevent teachers from telling
kids not to talk to their parents about
conversations with homosexuality is
egregious like it does a disservice to
the homosexual community yeah and now we
have the fact that you're learning that
teachers are hiding you know transgender
stuff from the listen that's the parents
kid 24 hours seven days a week it
doesn't become your kid teach them how
to write and read and send them home and
if the kid if the parents want them to
read about sex at you know whatever age
hopefully before you know by the time
they're 13 or 14 maybe
but you know there's nothing i've read
the bill it's just it's it's logical now
you know you could say the same thing
about why can't they talk about my
marriage with a man and a woman and no
just but
you know i've said this before there's
an over-representation of gay people in
the media there's a lot of gay people
work in the media tons of them
and those people amplify they make up
six percent of the population that's the
whole alphabet characters six percent
and that's you know on a in
they
amplify these causes
to a point where
you know years ago that didn't happen
and you're nowadays it happens because
they're afraid to be called homophobic
for not doing it what we need is for all
of these religious teachers to just have
discussions with five-year-olds about
the bible and then to tell those kids
don't let your parents know right can
you imagine can you imagine converting
their
this is also very important like as a
catholic you would absolutely never be
advised to
baptize someone else's child without
their permission because you imagine
well and also because like as a matter
of justice even though we have the full
truth
you don't own someone else's kid you
don't
think the idea that but this is the
point that they are such fervent
fanatics
they they own your child in their mind
so when you have this this case in
florida where the the student female
student was getting um therapies and
treatments without the parents knowing
that some of these are permanent oh yeah
imagine if a teacher baptized your kid
oh my god without you knowing and that's
not that's technically permanent but
it's not like altering their body you
know what i mean
it's just you know the fact that kids
are lonely and want to fit into a group
i remember going into the first gay club
and i think the issue was it was that
first moment i ever felt normal because
there were people like me around and
that was 1988 and i can't even imagine
today
what it feels like for them
that now you have to be part of this
group and that if you're not that you
know you're shunned or whatever but you
know i i see a point of it but it's also
a very very slippery slope that you're
making decisions young i mean i came out
in the aids
right dead center of it and
got out of it without a problem because
you know
safe sex and
that was it but
if you're young these days the pressures
on you to be something maybe you're not
is permanent nowadays because you know
once those surgeries and all that stuff
happen and then you know there's a
growing evidence of people who are now
saying i wish i hadn't done this that
they're not yeah blaire white's
interviewed more than one person i think
that they're saying that this was a
mistake i did it when i was young i
shouldn't have done it i was confused
well the issue is actually the the
algorithmic and media manipulation right
so this ties back to all the stuff
happening with elon musk
when you have
no people to explain a negative
circumstance you only hear a positive
circumstance and so what was happening
was there was a subreddit that was about
de-transitioning and it was people
telling their story saying you know i
didn't have a good time got banned there
was a website got pulled
any instance in which someone said let
me tell you this wasn't that great would
get removed for hate speech because
there was these these kids would then
only see a positive message right
because it became i don't know when it
happened because being gay you don't
think about it but i guess it was
probably like 10 years ago where
you know the pride and all this stuff
that comes out that you have to
celebrate this you know that that being
gay requires an extra level of
celebration and it has to you have to
accept it and especially as a parent you
have to accept that i want to be a man
now we went from tolerate to have to
yeah yeah and there's no middle ground
anymore and you know i've said this a
thousand times you know whoever owns the
language
owns everything and if you can say that
this is hate speech because you have
said that these people don't didn't
agree or had a really bad time
transitioning and here's 500 of them and
that somehow offends the other side that
you're not allowed to talk about it then
you're going to create a big and but
that's happening in our society with
everything this goes back to uh the
twitter conversation again in which
twitter's view of everything uh was that
it was it was all filtered through a
leftist lens correct and they kept
saying they weren't biased and
i'm trying to explain this to these guys
i'm like you're so biased you don't you
don't know you are you are surrounded by
nothing but people on the left no one
but leftist you've never talked to a
conservative so you assume when you hear
an opinion from a conservative it's a
fringe opinion that no one cares about
yes i get it your brother sister and
your friends agree with all of your
opinions you are not the world right i
find that the left tends to be
it's no surprise they tend to be um
atheist secular or outright condemn or
reject religion because they only view
they typically view themselves as the
universe as the universal center and
they're supposedly the most tolerant
which i was hysterical but the least
tolerant people you've ever met in your
life
and it's and it's kind of crazy that but
i think as they lose religion whatever
religion that is as they lose a sense
their religion becomes their identity
their sexual identity well what i mean
is that
people who
if you if you believe there's something
greater than you in any sense be it
spirituality be it the universe magnetic
fields you tend to treat other people
more equally because you're like i am a
person and you're a person and i must do
unto others as i would have them do unto
me but if you think there's nothing
there
well then you're going to be more ego
driven right you're going to be the one
standing on the podium saying i deserve
this right no one else correct that's
what we see a lot of they want everyone
else banned don't you say 90 words about
me you shouldn't be allowed to i should
well i think we're in a zero tolerance
for hurting people's feelings well and
this happened before when i spoke out on
the show
a few weeks ago and just mentioned that
i don't believe in gay marriage media
matters did a write-up on the show and
they also made it seem as if everyone on
the panel agreed with me right and it
was actually just you it was the last
thing they said they said tim cast are
all panelists
and it was who was it alex
brusowitz
it was uh the three of us and we both
were in agreement with gay marriage and
you weren't and they made it seem like
the whole show was and then media
matters is like watch out for these
grifters who will change their opinions
and it's like not a person here change
their opinion right they just make it up
yeah fake news you're saying people
don't tolerate what was it exactly
hurting other people's feelings or that
that's so i think that i think that
we're in a society we're hurting
someone's feelings is violence now i
don't i have low tolerance for malicious
behavior if there's someone's trying to
hurt someone maliciously then i'm going
to step in but if someone says something
that someone interprets and gets upset
about usually the person that's feeling
the upset it's in their mind right
there's something that they're going
through it's like being at a party with
all of us and he goes i don't really
just really not i my religion doesn't
conform to
gay marriage fine i don't believe in it
either like like i i you know i'm a
traditionalist in a lot of senses that
don't conform to
what might be good for me just because i
you know everyone's like you have to be
pro gay well no i i think this
institution kind of worked and i'm not
sure that you know but hey society
decided in their own legal ways that
that was the way it was going to be and
so be it
but that doesn't mean that those other
people vanish the day
you know that those court cases came
down those people are still there and
they should be able so what you're
saying for x amount of hundreds of years
of not having gay marriage is the minute
you have gay marriage none of those
people's opinions can exist anymore in
the same space and that is the problem i
have and that is
you can still be in the same room with
someone who doesn't agree that or that
just being gay is horrible or i'm going
to hell i mean who knows you know so the
point i'm trying to make is that those
opinions should be able to exist in the
same space one
doesn't get rid of the other one i want
to point out going back to this meme
from elon i think it's funny because if
you look at 2008
the far left person is actually right
wing in 2021 so going back to what james
was saying about barack obama yeah
so so we we focused on the guy in the
center the me and how the center becomes
you know changes now his right wing but
if the my fellow liberal stayed in this
spot on the left and moved down he would
he would be right center right in 2021
barack obama
running on universal health care in 2007
in 2008
and now they're calling him a republican
and the drone king
right
killing americans with drones
even clinton today would be um you know
some of their views and i lived through
that we were talking in the way here was
like what were the 90s like and i just
remember like
it just seemed less but see everyone
didn't have a voice and that was a good
thing there was no social media the
person who was crazy screamed at the end
of the road and now they have a twitter
account i think it is time that we start
ignoring
those who drove off the cliff and i'll
just say uh um
you i i am a staunch leftist here who
believes in universal basic healthcare
and you crazy conservatives oh i shake
my fist at you those other crazy guys
they had nothing to do with this
conversation anymore
this is this there's a new center now
let's pull the center back reassert what
left and right are and the crazy people
who drove off the cliff they're they
drove off the cliff they're not part of
this conversation i think the economics
for that are there meaning i think
you're seeing it with cnn i think you're
seeing it with cable news the one that
keeps
shrugging down the road is fox and the
right immediate right media seems to be
going quite well
and it's the left that seems to be kind
of going off the cliff because i think
that graphic says a lot about a lot of
people in the united states that
consider themselves democrats or left
and now look and go what am i what i
can't i say today when i when i was on
the daily wires backstage live i pointed
out the difference between us here i am
i'm you know i'm wearing jeans and an
unbuttoned shirt and they're all dressed
very very nice and and and we're all
we're having a conversation where we
mostly agree on a lot of issues like
voting for desantis versus trump i just
think it's funny that the issues that
would really divide us traditional
liberal versus traditional conservative
don't even come up because they're in
the they're on the back burner compared
to the greater problems we're facing
right
and we've faced worse and that's the sad
part like this country's gone through
even in my lifetime my god i got out of
high school and the economy was through
the ground and reagan and you know there
was a lot of we have the cold war we're
gonna die every day from like red dawn
and down for red october
that was our lives you know and there's
this giant war going on and at some
point russia is just going to be like
who are we fighting considering all the
and people are just like um just i don't
know and and the crazy things a lot of
millennials don't realize they were born
during the cold war yeah oh yeah and
their parents were crazy probably
drinking and smoking and that gave us
the millennials because there's got to
be an excuse for how this ended up the
way it did yeah but what i was saying is
i think social media and stuff about
what has changed in this like when i
grew up there wasn't school shootings
and
because kids got home
decompressed they got away from the
bullies they were able to spend time
with that geeky friends go back maybe
get bullied that day
now you have kids that can't ever get
away from this that they're connected to
this bullying and bad and good and bad
and i think also on the other end of the
spectrum i think in most societies
there's a lot of people who just don't
need to contribute what they need what
they're like just go scream in the
corner you know you know say it to your
parents and stuff but you there's some
people that just don't need to tell the
world like i've seen people i've seen
companies stop advertising and i think
it was harry's
with somebody from a twitter account
that said that they were this company
was it was a date might be the daily
that was they were anti-trans
and the the twitter follower had like 38
followers yeah that was harry's razors
and they had so
there's a disproportionate amount of
power that a lot of these people have i
think you make a good point about
evidence for why public school is
failing as well because it's creating an
environment where kids are getting
bullied on the regular whereas this
consistent bullying they they can't
escape it so it's another reason not to
put young people in that
environment i'm just fascinated that
from where i grew up
you know just going back to what i was
mentioning before about backstage live
is like even having this conversation
with sheamus most of the political
conversations we have are on things we
completely agree on and we only ever so
often touch on the things we don't agree
on even though you and i disagree on
some stuff to a great degree
but the the cultural battles we're
fighting
free speech
individual liberties personal
responsibility all of these things that
used to be just
an american value given it was a given
yeah now it's like okay those other
things are here like we'll discuss them
but man those people are crazy well what
we've gone to now is some people can
some people have different
abilities to say what they can and some
people can't you know a catholic can't
say to me
that i don't have a value and i'm not
all like
it's well we wouldn't say you don't have
value as a person no yeah we would say
they believe homosexual homosexual
activity is sinful yeah and you know we
live in a jessie smullet
world where
you know he represented everything i saw
coming down the track and like you're
going to commit this a giant crime
to become a victim
is you know i remember when what's her
name said she was black and remember
back yeah
and or the first time i heard safe space
and thought
that's never gonna take you know and
people are like these kids are getting
out of school and they're gonna bully
them because they know how to use social
media but social media had gotten to a
point and you're right and i see it in
the media where a lot of these older
editors are scared to death of like
taylor lorenz you know what it is
there's some 40 or 50 year old dude who
works at a company and the millennial
you know comes out and says i haven't
got a job here then they go i demand a
safe room and they go what are you
talking about
so then they go on twitter next thing so
we don't have a safe room this 50 year
old guy gets 30 tweets and it's like you
are an evil man you're evil and they're
like what's happening
everyone is tweeting at me yeah i've
seen it happen i've seen that happen
i've seen it happen it's not just a
question of what you're allowed to say
it's a question of what the people you
have associated with are allowed to say
or rather who you're allowed to
associate with based on what they've
said so i don't like to pay too much
attention to celebrities but before the
show we were discussing the fact that
chris pratt
is being canceled they're trying to
recast him right because according to
some twitter mob his church is
anti-lgbtq
and we cannot have an actor in a film
who goes to a church that we believe is
anti-lgbtq i just want to remind
everyone i just want to remind everyone
that
the former president of the united
states barack obama
went to a church
with reverend wright
as the preacher who said in a sermon
that was leaked that the united states
government invented hiv to kill black
people yes barack obama attended that
church for years and when this footage
leaked the media said no that's mean to
talk about and every conservative in
media went okay fine we won't talk about
that even though it's literally true but
the chris pratt thing was that story
goes back i think several years to
uh that
the actor this actor individual saying
he goes to this church it's an old story
and the new story is because i think
james gunn responded to a twitter
account that had three followers so
i'm you know no chris pratt's not going
anywhere yeah but it's just interesting
that people would actually see that as
something that was worthy of getting a
person cancelled and could effectively
get them canceled because we've seen
people get in trouble for that holding
on to the past the tweet
was
someone tweeted
hey marvel
you know recast him they didn't say why
james gunn invented the reason why
saying why because he believes things
you don't he's not going anywhere and
i'm like well hold on what does he
believe and then the people google his
twitter account this right this twitter
account with three followers didn't say
anything about religion or politics it
just said hey cast this guy the person
then said i posted that because i saw
the actor and thought they looked alike
right that was it james gunn injected
cancel culture into the narrative
it was like a weird inverse
cancel culture i think to be fair there
were so many articles flooding the
internet over chris pratt's church that
i think it makes sense that he would
read that i think i think
and this
with this that story was years ago bro
yeah no i know but they're just people
are going to try to cancel somebody it's
probably going to be the thing they were
trying to cancel over a few years ago
the issue is if you say this is what i
think about gay and this is what i think
is going to happen and i listen to you
great that's your views the problem
today is
what i would do is find out what it is
about you that i have to destroy to stop
you
instead of just engaging with you and
said you know i think you're absolutely
right because those are your beliefs
this is my beliefs because that's how it
happened this is what i believe god did
whatever and so much and so on now this
person being me would have to find the
deepest darkest bad thing you've ever
done
say it on twitter to then nullify that
you had an opinion that i didn't agree
with and that's where we are and that's
the problem is that no one can just
disagree
and then media matters is out there
saying
you know because
this is not how
this this is not how civil society
should work we should just be able to
say like yeah you know i have plenty i
have family members who didn't think it
was great you know
but i agree that they that's their
opinion and they love each other we love
each other and that's the end of it well
yeah i mean the modern ethos says no one
can disagree with me without being a
horrifically corrupt person and also if
someone does disagree with me we have to
ensure that they're never allowed it's
also it's imbalanced my the
lgbt it's mostly coming from the left
the lgbt side of it says you have to
love me and embrace my lifestyle and you
have to put a flag and do all these
other things and change your logos
that's not how i view life because
what if they said okay every x amount of
month we have to put
religious symbols up be based right
but no it well and also this idea of
love this idea that loving someone means
you have to agree with everything
they're doing and that's what we've lost
yeah let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and head over
to timcast.com
become a member and help support our
work and our journalists we just hired a
new journalist recently we're going to
be doing a lot of really cool stuff
we're planning you know many
documentaries new shows we are planning
on uh beginning marketing doing other
really cool things as you all know we
got a billboard in times square calling
out uh taylor lorenz the washington post
i'm very proud of that thank you all for
your support in making that possible
let's read what you guys have to say
adara the wholesome says tim you're
wrong the only name for a free damastan
coffee shop is coffee there is no
exception anything else is an ian level
natural one semantic argument no bs just
coffee
too
political keep your politics out of my
mouth
i have that printed on the coffee cup
that tweet
richard winter says the battle of helm's
deep has turned it's time to charge and
finish this battle i just watched that
recently i love that scene ride out with
me one last time and then they storm
through and they knock all the orcs out
of the way and then gandalf is there and
they're like that's a great scene yeah
that's what happened it was elon musk
though
then he blinds the orcs as they stampede
rising underdog says still want tim to
have adam carolla on as a guest to
discuss his book in 50 years we'll all
be chicks and the pacification of
america
uh i would be honored to have adam kroll
on the show that'd be great
remember love line yeah back in the day
i was just thinking about that yeah him
and dr drew yeah that's right that's
kind of bizarre that they were together
because dr drew is such a kind of
mainstream milk toast figure whereas
adam kroll is probably really
politically incorrect no i
know to our point on the show
uh used to air on cue 101 or roll in
chicago listening to that
and they had a girl with them too didn't
they did they dr judy no i think she had
her own show i love this justin bowman
says elon said quote look to my coming
at the first light on the fifth day at
dawn look east that's right he did
that's what he said can someone just
make that meme that'd be good yeah just
put put his face on it
and then all of the people the rohirrim
are all the people who are banned all
rushing back in with him
the orcs
uh see sith hammer says trump's first
post on truth social i'm back kaffifi
is he is he i thought that wasn't me is
that real did he actually post that i
saw a screenshot i wasn't sure the
problem with true social is it's only on
the iphone
and so and it just started working when
i first did it you didn't have you
couldn't put you'd you'd upload your
picture but it didn't show up well they
got they're on rumble's
new
crowds all right raymond g stanley jr
says
tim they are scared of free speech in
the town square for they fear that they
themselves and their views will
disappear into and lost to history
interesting
you said they four times that's right by
the way then eva ranska says finally
subscribe to your website thank you for
supporting truth in journalism you bet
every day we uh work really hard
and i'm in the newsroom and if i see a
story i'll be like guys guys you got to
change this so we do we do a lot of
corrections because we want to make sure
we're getting things right we even do
what i would call frame checking where
we make sure the framing of the story
there was one story we had where it was
like joe biden criticized over these
things and i said nope
doing a story about how conservatives
are criticizing joe biden i think is not
news
make a story about what joe biden did
and then include what the left thinks
and with the right things we don't frame
our stories like biden can dance over
this i mean that's how the media
operates and it's like well you know you
know
the left destroyed the rights arguments
or you know
republicans pounce famously if it's an
opinion piece i got no issue with it
right well now there's no more opinion
now it's all the same like there are
things i even as an editor look on
certain sites i used to work at and
there was no way three four five years
ago that that headline and that stuff
would go without an opinion the
huffington post is an opinion website
database is an opinion website and they
they and vox but they masquerade as news
and you read it and i'm like those are
all opinion statements
they're not telling me something
happened so
all right
let's see
tam tam tom says instead of spending 100
grand on a billboard why not have a
drawing for your website members and
give away 10 grand to 10 members
actually help us regular folk who
support you
um i mean that would be cool we could do
something like that and that would
actually be an excellent marketing
campaign which would increase membership
we'll do both the issue with the
billboard that we did was that it's
actually substantially cheaper than that
substantially cheaper i don't think
people understand how cheap it is let me
let me explain some of you guys
do you want to know how much it costs to
have your ad run on a billboard in times
square let's get a round of guesses i'm
saying well i think you guys already
know yeah we guessed it
before i guessed correctly he was close
and i was closer 18
did you not know this that's all is
google search it and there are automated
services where you log in
they'll give you the specs for the ad
and they'll say how many times you want
to run and they say it costs 18 times
per 18 dollars per run they may have a
minimum of like 100 runs or whatever so
it's like okay
you need 1800
maybe not everybody can afford that but
it's not a hundred if you want to get
like that big one right underneath the
xinhua thing on olive garden that one
costs 625 000
per week
that's crazy
but most of these ads
are uh most these billboards are
rotating digital video and it's not that
expensive uh not only that there's a
whole bunch of different ads you can get
there's there you can go up to the
biggest billboard in times square for
you know 2.5 million per month down to
the parking the the bench on the side of
the road which is like literally a
hundred dollars they're like well the
bench is dirt cheap it'll cost you 300
bucks for the month
so
if you want to get
i don't i don't the the billboard
i don't want to give i don't want to
give away too many details because
there's other companies involved thanks
to taylor around so you know everything
about billboards well i mean
it takes five minutes to google
so you guys you're talking about people
are saying hey troll uh times square yes
it's easy now there are laws and there
are rules about what you can include in
ads but yo for real got a couple hundred
bucks you can get your ad to run right
next to abc news in times square for a
couple hundred bucks for the day it is
not that expensive so people are like
can you believe two pools spent hundreds
of thousands of dollars to do this
it costs almost nothing it's it's
they're expensive when you're doing big
campaigns
but you also got to understand that the
with the economy you know crumpling by
1.4 percent yeah
yo these these these ad agencies i'm
willing to bet are kind of like just
let's let's book people as much as we
can
so google search it guys because um
i'm i'm really surprised
you know i
i always wondered why it was more people
didn't buy billboards and and make
statements and do things like we did
with taylor lorenz calling her out
how come more people aren't doing it
how could more people aren't being like
i'll put a couple hundred bucks behind
this how come no one's created like a go
fund well not go fund me but it gives
send go yes saying we're gonna raise 50
grand for a four week run oh my god on
one of the biggest billboards
and then we're gonna put up a message
they'll do it there are rules if it's a
statement involving other people it
cannot be an advertisement so you won't
be able to include links but
you can quite literally put up a sign
saying cnn lies all day every day and
that's all it says and i'll be like sure
we'll put that up i don't care give us
your money
and then if you get a bunch of your
friends together and you get a couple
grand you'll have like one of the
smaller billboards
not that expensive granted some of it
can be expensive but the the bobo that
we got was nowhere near that expensive
it depends well to put it to put it
bluntly depends on how long the ad runs
for
hours did not run that long tim actually
sent ian and i out there with paint
brushes
vanessa mccullough says please please
listen to falling in reverse zombified
it's about the culture war the video is
a must watch i'm also a member thank you
for your work you want to take take a
note of that you want to write that down
i'll watch
yeah
let's grab some super chats
never again says i wrote the code for
5.1 surround for solaris shared to all
yet apple never thanked me all others
did at linux rocks
it does was that uh carry on is the
following and reverse song you're
talking about zodify
joe biden is a kid diddler says
day one musk should move the company to
texas and turn the campus into a
homeless shelter agreed i tweeted that
and got 50 000 likes
that he should move to
i said if he gets it he should move it
to texas absolutely and it was quite
popular but then he had a lot of people
in texas like don't bring these people
here please yeah fortunately they work
from home so i don't think they'll go
with them michael lamour says just
started a membership recently parts of
that discussion with derrick harvey the
other evening were wild to listen to
yes and that was great after we wrapped
i think it was it uh jack and you or is
it who was being champions yeah it was
two of us we probably spoke with him for
another 40 minutes yeah yeah i was able
to see the middle east policy just
asking so i was like we should just
record that because the stories he was
telling about what was going on there
was nuts yeah but we we we do have time
for limits and stuff plus i got to wake
up at 7am but uh we definitely got to
have derrick back
so you can just talk about all this
stuff
all right thomas sidebottom says it
would seem i received my leftist tears
tumbler from the daily wire at exactly
the right time oh yeah wonderful we got
a free one of those too they gave us one
of those free tumblers so cool i love it
yeah
all right
sean elmer says i wish you would invite
some first amendment auditors such as
long island audits or watching the
watchmen and his dad both are on the
front line of that movement very
reasonable people interesting we'll take
a look into it
all right
raymond g stanley jr says lydia madame a
super congratulations on your union with
andy we wish you well the best button
pusher and producer in the game
f sour patch kids oh thank you
congratulations did win i beat sour
patch kid you guys tied the knot today
we do yeah today was our six month
anniversary so we were like we should do
it today even though it's a thursday oh
nice work well congratulations thank you
thank you
all right voice of junzi says hello tim
cast i'm a conservative youtuber that
makes essay and analyses on video games
i believe we need voices in these spaces
as the industry is the forefront of art
love you guys help me grow a voice of
junsie very very cool
i had an idea for a documentary series
and it was to
make many documentaries around video
game concepts
uh we did this with fallout from
fukushima fallout 4 was coming out we
said let's go investigate fukushima and
see what's going on with the radiation
stuff and then i had the idea they
didn't want to do it i guess
but i was like when these new video
games come out like call of duty let's
do a call of duty themed investigation
into what are these weapons who actually
trains for them
how close to reality these video games
get
and and i actually i think i'm i think
um
the the pitch was like can we get the
companies to actually
co-sponsor
the documentaries because it would be
like an ad for them oh god yeah
all right tom torgeson says
torgersen i am a trucker from detroit
and listen to your show the day after
it's live i'm addicted
looking forward to some coffee beanie in
the future thanks for all you do ian
watch waking life great movie i've seen
it before and i agree it was well i
didn't think it was great but it was
really cool
yeah
all right
ron quay says tim you always talk about
the right the right to nuclear arms
brandon herrera the ak guy was on rokita
last night and he is an ffl he said
there is a form for nuclear arms sales
which surprised even him it shouldn't
surprise you good sir the right to keep
and bear arms says arms i don't see it
saying except nuclear arms no it says
arms
arms
a conscious perspective says hey irl
team here's a thought what if elon knew
about the inflated subscriber numbers
and put all this into motion to expose
twitter and then be able to renegotiate
his original offer thoughts no i don't
think so
i think he played them cornered them and
knows what he's doing
i think he's going to buy the platform
i do
so what could happen at this point that
would prevent him from actually he gets
a billion dollars
if they if they break it off he gets a
billion dollars so what what could cause
them to break it off if the shareholders
yeah
at this point nothing okay because it's
the offer is too sweet their stock has
gone down this earnings more problems
the shareholders want and then the
company would lose a billion dollars and
elon would get a billion dollars
they're not gonna
it's not unless
there's some shady business going on and
they did you see that the fcc people
wrote to the fcc about stopping it the
fcc the ftc and the doj
and the fcc was just like this is absurd
yeah they actually was absurd yep
all right raymond gently junior says i
played will of the people for my bro he
liked oh very nice we just uh i posted
on instagram it's saying it's an
isolated vocal track of the new chicken
city theme song
and uh if you want to hear me sing the
second verse about roberto and roberto
jr you can check that out on my
instagram instagram.comtimcast
it was fun and we'll put up we we've got
a bunch of other songs we're working on
so cool stuff i think ian's going to
track some harmonies for chicken city
chicken city probably next week unless
carter is ready soon we'll check in with
him tomorrow
i'm watching you carter
carter banks ladies and gentlemen
citizen 7 says tim do you have a youtube
account named tim p whatsapp plus
130254.86574
asterix question mark question mark
question mark this account has replied
to a couple of my comments in here and i
fear it's a phishing attempt
that is in fact not made it's not tim no
yeah someone must be impersonating wait
hold on bro i've been sending oh my
goodness have you been sending i've been
replying
i thought you needed my social security
number bro
i actually do
oh well i sent it
what are you waiting for not to me
oh ask them for it
all right stronger than stone says do
you think elon could buy youtube how
awesome it would be if he did the future
is looking bright but the distance i
still still see a storm
storm get ready to put on your raincoats
take care y'all elon cannot buy youtube
youtube's way too big yeah and i don't
think it's a publicly traded company
it's an asset of you know alphabet yeah
is it alphabet or is it google i think
it's still google but alphabet owns
google right or maybe they broke it up i
don't know
all right he's got as much debt as he
needs right now
real man pro says hey team cast romanian
mountain man here
quote victory is written with the blood
of the vanquished and it perfectly
represents the new age of culture p.s
ian the love of my eardrums it it's go
bells not gerbals
no gerbils thank you go balls
go balls it is
go balls
brew that do says to help pay for your
next billboard we'll see
i am um in preliminary discussions with
some
particular individuals about some
very basic billboards that will result
in a woke implosion and put it that way
so the idea is just to like
hey do you want to get a billboard just
promoting you
because we know that when these people
see these billboards in times square
they're going to be like no
because it's not that expensive it is
expensive don't get me wrong if you want
to get a good spot like i said the big
one 625 000 per week but there are so
many in times square and you're not
buying the whole billboard you're buying
and some of these things it is a 15
second digital video in an 18 minute
rotation so it's not as much as people
might think it is they make their money
on volume
yeah it's going to be a whole lot of fun
we're just going to try and spat her a
bunch of ads all over the place and the
thing is for these agencies they don't
care it's going to be like so-and-so's
new book coming out check it out
timcast.com and people are going to see
this dude's face and they're going to be
you're going to trend i've already said
you're going to trend on twitter oh yeah
well we'll see how it plays out we'll
see how it plays out
all right let's see we got
l phones alphonse says shout out to lids
for calling m.o great yesterday
libertarian culture ozarks caves and
toasted ravioli i love that
we had constitutional carry before texas
and our pizza makes chicago's looks like
poo-poo garbage excuse me y'all should
have moved here instead the best state
in the union that's a great state what
state missouri missouri wow well you're
the set unit they say missouri loves
company
man well you know what you know what
they say gotta get a slice of that
missouri pizza that's right no we can't
man sure
chicago pizza look real bad we special
order missouri pizza because it's so
fantastic
missouri
no no
we laugh at you we know i'm kidding i
love missouri but the pizza thing come
on get out of here east st louis pizza
because it's still illinois and illinois
has chicago
no it doesn't count sorry
all right eight uh adam brennaman says
jimmy kimmel stopped doing celebrities
read mean tweets after obama read
trump's tweet then said trump would
never be president oh right that was a
great moment yikes oh brutal man that's
right that was so good mike ass says
disney doesn't say gay in china
that's right that's for sure am says
just scared the chickens awake per super
chat whilst they were sleeping sorry oh
no chickens
so uh the issue the issue is that uh
crispy are chicken tender crispy crispy
chicken tenders
on a secret mission and unable to uh
take care of the speaker being going off
but i think they've taken care of it all
right now because they're back i just
had a thought about obama trash talking
trump and basically encouraging him to
run against him like in a war you don't
torture he did it at the white house
correspondents dinner so you know when
he in a real war you don't torture your
opponents when you beat them and then so
we're in a culture war at what point is
it considered torturing people when
they're down like taylor lorenz like i
want to lay off this girl right now
because she's kept held captive and i
don't want to torture the woman you know
i think there's some people who kind of
deserve it and you know torture
well i'm not saying
criticism
but if we're really in a culture wharf
we're going to use these metaphors at
what point is criticism torturous so the
issue is that she calls criticism
torture and it's like the first time
she's ever experienced any kind of
contrary voice to her owning because i
don't think we're in a culture i would
say if it becomes harassment i would say
if you were like actually legitimately
harassing a person
i think because
if you make a good point against someone
and then they're basically at your at
your
will after that you have them then you
keep going at them that that's a form of
torture
it's definitely not pleasant stuff i
don't know i don't know it's not
military yeah it's culture war torture i
don't want to soften the word torture
that's my concern with that i don't want
to stop that i don't like the word
culture interesting interesting
all right amanda freeman says san diego
passed law to redefine women to include
men please discuss this well i don't
know too much about that law but um
that's about most okay interesting
i mean i'm pretty sure new york
essentially has that as well what a
historic occasion upon which people have
right time for this oh my goodness i bet
they they really think they did
something there how come everyone's
putting one in the chat did tim said
that that's that's you ian tim must have
done something that was totally tim yeah
all right jacob frederick says hey shim
and crew love the show but i've heard
you talk about indiana being a pretty
good conservative state before but i beg
to differ since we have one of the
highest gas taxes in the country and our
governor vetoed a ban on a trans men in
women's sports
that's messed up they shouldn't have
done that however
i don't think you're gonna move to cook
county anytime soon because of how bad
indiana is getting all i'm saying is
compared to where we came from
indiana's doing decently i am very upset
to hear what you just mentioned though
because that's completely unacceptable
once the red states go there's nowhere
left it's fear they're scared to death
trans people scare they scare me and i'm
a gay man like they're terrifying there
you get the mad boy
see that's that i take uh uh issue with
that though to be honest because it's
it's it's the ideology it's the cult
it's not
yeah i mean there are plenty of people
who have you know issues a woke
progressive liberal woman at a school
teaching these kids things which is is
is the issue right right oh my god yeah
and i always say this because
you know there there are trans people
who clearly agree with us on
ideologically but also there's there's
this erasure of women where you know
there's what was it the
thing came out the other day that it's a
uterus department education came out of
the video that said that it's
a person with a uterus
of course yeah the way i see it is
this is predominantly an issue of white
liberal women yes and then to a lesser
degree men they're they're you know
it's not an issue of trans people it's
an issue of the weird cult which is
predominantly like you know millennial
white progressives
you've got these teachers who are in
these schools
and they're not all trans some of them
are non-binary but a lot of what we see
in these rant videos are just like
unwell people who are cultish right i
mean it's the same thing that when i was
growing up that you're going to turn
kids gay if you talk about it and so
forth and
you know i don't i have a lot of
straight tons of more straight friends
and gay friends and trust me you're if a
guy likes a woman you're not going to
turn him as much you can try to convince
him all you want nothing's gonna all
right john sanchez says tim poole duel
me in magic the gathering you coward uh
well i only play commander for the most
part and you'd be you'd be obliterated
like
ian and i stopped playing because it got
to the point where whoever went first
one yeah too much pay to win in a draft
though you might have a chance no i'd
still win
we would like gauntlet
we roll a d20 and then you know ian
would get a 15 i'd get a seven i go oh
good game me and i shake his hand i'm
playing slay the spire lately that's my
card game what is that digital card game
one of the best math games ever made if
you like turn based strategy games check
out slay the spire
right on all right joseph
albacon says 67 year old boomer here and
long time subscriber i may not be key
demographic but been following you for
five or six years now fantastic guest
wish i was there since i have so much to
add well thank you for for your support
absolutely
all right john l says if you're going to
watch the zombified vid you need to
check out
5fdp livingthedreamvid
it's covid policy explained interesting
ross boisvert says tim and crew i'm an
at t business rep if you want a second
look at options shoot me a message on
twitter
at the new rossgb and i can get you my
work contact info
yeah maybe but like you know when i walk
in and i have impeccable credit and i'm
running this business and i say we just
need you know hot spot wi-fi and they're
alike looks like the company is
requiring you i'm like nah not
interested have a nice day not gonna
happen
you know i i i am not really a fan of
having to do certain kind of like
special privilege things
i don't i don't like the idea that
people use twitter followings as weight
to gain favors from companies i don't
like that or complain about them
right like if you're sitting on an
airline stop shut up no one wants to
hear about your late flight but here's
what i don't like
when i was dealing with an airline
problem i tweet once
the problem is solved they call me
instantly we're so sorry sir and i know
it works and sometimes you have to do it
but i'm like it's so stupid that this
has to be this way
that you have to
shave them well it's right
i should be able to calm up and be like
hey man treat me and everyone else like
good paying customers if you it's like a
two-hour wait to call an airline these
days either they're not insane yeah and
so
that's the way it is it's it's privilege
through all the money and the politics
there's just nothing that compares to
having a mob of people behind you no or
a crowd of people behind you like it's
just unstoppable force and they're
scared that's what the money's supposed
to buy when it's effective right
daniel smith says tim fact check your 16
food pressing plant fire story great
youtuber 2a advocate johnny b mentioned
the tim cast article in his deep dive
video he only found like six actual
fires we did i was mildly perturbed at
the um the quality of that article it
was not good
and i even said the story should have
been framed as
tucker carlson was talking about it
people on twitter were talking about it
but you need to understand fires might
just happen all the time and we may just
have noticed them however it is true
because we did the fact checking there
actually were substantially more fires
this year in the first quarter than i
think all of last year yeah so something
did happen
but um you know we just had bad links
and bad sources and so you know these
things happen i got no problem saying
that uh we
we make mistakes we correct them when we
can you know we try not to make mistakes
if we were like the daily beast we would
just say no and we'd leave it up for the
clicks because the daily beast doesn't
correct their articles
all right
t
dynamis says i can't believe tim poole
spent so much money on a times square at
haromf
yeah uh we didn't it's so cheap yeah it
was really crazy i was always wondering
like how does this stuff work and then i
googled it and it's like log in
submit your ad and we'll play it and i'm
like it's that fast yo they're just tv
screens but also you if you want an
analogous of that at the moment you had
a fire you took 18
of gasoline and just threw it on it
because whatever you paid for the thing
was six i mean that thing that was a
picture of that went everywhere oh yeah
i took a cross and shouted us out i saw
it and friend in spain daily wire hooked
it up you know went everywhere yeah
daley wire already had the billboard and
then the secondary story was her
responding and then you know
her being upset
you know my issue with it is just that
she uses the washington post as a weapon
this is what these these journalists do
they're they're they're typically
activists they have no real power so
they get jobs at major institutions and
it's like they it's like they're using
someone else's 50 cal yeah so i said let
me let me play the same game that's what
i feel like you get a billboard how i
feel about the president man these
people get elected through a popularity
contest and then they get all this
institutional power like what right does
he have to create a board of mistrust
that he's going to start yeah that's
crazy that's an abusive it's an abuse of
institutional power and menthol
cigarettes all the same yeah
all right
i want to mention this again about
taylor lorenz the woman was on msnbc
literally crying because she said she's
so worried about what people might do
with her information so she knows there
are bad actors online and even dangerous
actors online and she finds someone who
she doesn't like politically and she
throws their address out to the public
yep yep all right everybody if you
haven't already smash that like button
and subscribe to timcast.com become a
member and we're gonna have a members
only show coming up at 11 p.m tonight
don't uh you don't want to miss these
they're usually fun and we swear a lot
and they're not so family friendly and
uh smash that like button like i said
subscribe share the show with your
friends you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at tim cast
john do you want to shout anything out
you can follow me at newspolitics on
twitter that's all i have to sell
my name for good media backgrounds
anything in media boy i got it
nice my name is sheamus i have a youtube
channel called freedom tunes we make
animated political cartoons every single
thursday one exception was this thursday
we had to pull back but we're doing
multiple videos next week instead so
we'll make it up to you guys i love you
amazing i'm gonna roll the hundred sided
it's been a while i rolled a 29. oh it's
a beautiful prime number very cool i'll
catch you later
you guys may follow me on twitter at
mines.com at sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatchlids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you